apple killed the long beloved 27-inch
imac and there are five specific reasons
why they did in this video we'll not
only explain exactly how and why they
did that but also talk about what the
chances are that they will bring it back
and if they do which i'll explain why i
do believe that will happen
when you should expect it helping you
guys to decide if you should just buy
the mac studio or a mac mini paired to
the studio display or hold off for the
redesigned 27-inch imac first off the
proof that they actually killed it at
the event they kept referencing how much
more powerful the mac studio was than
the 27-inch imac now this got my
attention because they usually don't do
this unless the new model is a direct
replacement for the old one that they
are comparing to turns out i was right
because after the 27-inch imac was
nowhere to be found on their site the
imac in the navigation bar only shows
the 24 inch one and even if you manually
type into the url for the 27 inch imac
they set it up to automatically redirect
to the 24 inch model now for those of
you guys that might think that they just
removed it so that nobody will buy it
while apple waits to update that to
apple silicon that is simply not true
because the intel mac mini is still
there and we know that the m2 mini is
coming soon so apple is still keeping
that hundred dollar intel mac mini model
there right between the seven hundred
dollar m1 mini and the two thousand
dollar mac studio while they wait to
replace it and to finish it off at the
end of the event apple said that there
is only one mac left to transition to
apple silicon before their two year
transition period is over and that is
the mac pro
and if you have any more doubts they
even reply to rs technica after their
article and confirmed that the 27-inch
imac has reached end of life or has been
discontinued so with all that said why
did they kill the 27-inch imac that was
such an iconic machine for apple being
steve jobs favorite as well as such a
great deal giving you everything you
need in an all-in-one quick and easy to
set up machine especially at its base
price of just eighteen hundred dollars
for a whole computer of the keyboard the
mouse and that beautiful display what's
crazy is for close to the 1800 price you
now only get a display one that has been
pretty much the same in the last eight
years in the imac at 5k resolution since
2014 but by the time you add in the
cheapest mac out there in apple's
keyboard and the mouse you're at 2550
instead of the previous 1800 for the
imac and of course you don't get that
sleek all-in-one design and the fact
that you now can't upgrade the ram
yourself which allowed you to save more
money in the past so there is a massive
price difference now well once again
there are five reasons that they killed
it and the first reason is the new
studio display people have been asking
for a new higher resolution apple brand
display even before that 2011 1440p
thunderbolt display was discontinued but
when they got rid of it in 2016 they
didn't replace it because there wasn't
enough sales and profit in displays so
instead they let lg make their own
version with apple's input but most
people just weren't happy with its
plastic design and wobbly stand even if
it had the same 5k panel that is an
apple's imax with that the imac was a
way better deal if you already knew that
you wanted a nice display which is why
we told most of you guys just to go out
and buy the imac instead of a mac mini
with lg's 5k display now if apple was to
get back into the display game like
people kept asking for they would need
to make sure that it sold well and the
best way is to force people to buy it
instead of getting a much better deal
with a 5k imac now if apple would have
released a redesigned 27-inch imac at
the same time as the mac studio and the
studio display i guarantee a lot of
people including ourselves would have
just bought the imac because it's such a
better value getting rid of the imac
guarantees that more people buy the
studio display with the mac studio now
bringing in enough profit to make having
a nice aluminum display for people to
pair with their mac minis their macbooks
and their studio max as well as helping
more people want to buy the upcoming
apple silicon mac pro since they will no
longer have to buy or want to buy that
crazy expensive 6k xdr display heck even
if they did not make a new redesigned
imac right now but they still kept the
intel model on the website some people
would have still bought that intel 5k
imac right now
because of the huge difference in value
and because of the fact that the 2020
27-inch intel imac is still surprisingly
powerful which leads me into reason
number two which is that apple could not
make the m1 ultra chip work well enough
in the 27-inch imac redesign i will
explain why and why this matters right
now
we first started talking about the m1
max duo as we called it back in november
after getting leaks on the 20 core
processor coming out and later in
december we broke the hidden connector
on the bottom the m1 max and how it will
be used to create the m1 max duo now
known as the m1 ultra in that first
video we showed off how the redesigned
imac could keep up with a chip like this
and keep it cool in such a thin chassis
but it turns out that we were probably
wrong about it being possible because of
what apple had to do with the mac studio
in my 13 secrets video i mentioned how
the m1 ultra max studio weighs 2 pounds
more than the m1 max version and just as
i suspected the reason why is the
cooling solution
apple confirmed that the ammon ultra
version has a better cooler that is made
out of copper instead of aluminum and
weighs almost two pounds more in order
to keep the 20 cpu cores and the 64
graphics cores cool enough if apple had
to make the mac studio so much larger
than the mini in order to keep these
ships cool it literally looks like half
of the studio is just cooling solution
then they would have had to keep the
same older thicker imac design like the
imac pro with those dual fans to keep
the m1 ultra thermals under control
without having throttling or without
running super loud and we know that with
apple upgrading all of their devices to
modern flat sided designs there is no
way that they are going to keep the imac
that same exact design that's been
around for over 10 years now just in
order to be able to use the m1 ultra
which leads me to the next one some
people would say why wouldn't apple just
put the m1 max into the 27 inch and be
fine with that
well we here at max tech didn't think
that apple would let this happen for
many reasons and we talked about it
months ago if we look at the prior years
apple usually only upgrades their max
when there is enough of a performance
reason to do so so they'll either wait
for better cpus or graphics before they
make an update even though the m1 max
was a massive jump from the intel 16
inch macbooks if you compare it to the
two year old 8 and 10 core intel cpus in
their latest 27 inch imacs the raw
performance is actually worse with the
m1 max chip than the intel processors
and that would be embarrassing for apple
now as far as graphics the 32 core
version is faster than amd's 5700 x but
not by that much especially in raw
performance tasks if they would have
released a redesigned 27-inch imac with
only the m1 max in many ways it would be
a slower computer and it would also be
limited with lower amounts of ram as
well now with that every time apple has
shown off a new chip with apple silicon
they have shown how it absolutely
destroyed the previous intel models but
with the imac this would not have been
the case and the top it off they have
way more pressure now because of intel's
super powerful alder lake processors to
keep the apple silicon performance hype
and marketing going that they've built
up they would need to release a
competitive chip that would have huge
gains over the previous imac and that
would compete with intel's alder lake
and that simply would not be possible
with the m1 max in the 27 inch imac and
many of us would simply be disappointed
about that just how people are
disappointed when that same m1 came out
to the 24 inch imac and a lot of people
that need more power would start looking
once again to different pc options and
with that leads me into the next one the
average sales price the imac has always
started really low in terms of pricing
but if you wanted to get the best
performance apple would let you spend
way more money which is what they want
up to eight thousand two hundred dollars
in 2020. if they put out an imac with
only an m1 max their average sales price
would go down quite a bit and in these
times of rising costs for materials chip
shortages higher shipping costs there is
no way they would want to do that now
instead not only can they compete with
intel and nvidia but they can sell the
mac studio for even more money higher
average sales price than the imac before
at up to eight thousand dollars for the
computer itself plus the price of the
display the keyboard and the mouse
overall raising the cost while having
lower uh raising the price of it by
having lower costs for themselves since
they make these own chips so that is
great profit for apple and lastly apple
is trying to change their branding and
they've been doing a great job at it
from being a company who doesn't listen
to their customers to one that cares a
lot and has much better brand perception
like they used to have going from being
against ports and offering usb type-c
only now bringing back the ports that
they said they didn't need like the sd
card readers hdmi and magsafe they got
rid of the much hated butterfly
keyboards as well as the touch bar and
they made their macbooks thicker and
with larger batteries which they didn't
want to do before and now not only are
they offering a new display the
standalone that people have been asking
for as they are also offering a super
powerful stand-alone computer that's not
tied to a display at least one that
doesn't cost six thousand dollars at the
base price and shockingly they are now
offering front i o an sd card reader
which i think would have never happened
under johnny ive so will apple ever make
another imac well like i said i
definitely think so for two reasons
first off if you look at the studio
display it is actually fairly thick much
thicker than needed for a 5k lcd display
now my 6k xdr is close to that in
thickness but two thirds of it is
actually that cheese grater cooling
design that draws heat from the display
that can reach a thousand six hundred
nits peak brightness the studio display
doesn't have this cheese grater cooling
that requires a lot of thickness and it
also doesn't get anywhere near as bright
as that display and we see in the
macbooks the xdr displays actually are
super thin anyways so why is it so thick
when the m1 imac with the chipset and
everything that is there including those
massive channels behind the screen for
the speakers it's just so much thinner
along with that we also have a lot of
cooling vents across the whole bottom as
well so that just pretty much tells me
that this whole enclosure and the
thickness is pretty much designed to be
an imac and with that we have also had
rumors of an imac being in production
and just a few days ago we actually have
updates from reputable sources showing
that an imac pro will come out and it
will have an m2 pro and m2 pro max chip
in it with the updated m2 ultra being
saved for the mac studio probably due to
cooling so when will it come out and is
it worth waiting for it well since apple
said that there's only one more mac that
they are going to be transitioning from
intel to apple silicon in that two-year
period which ends this winter
we also know that that is the mac pro
not the imac that means that we should
not expect the redesigned imac to come
out before that now the 27-inch imac
didn't yet get transitioned as we know
obviously but instead of transitioning
it they just flat out dropped it from
their site that means that they're not
planning to have a transition in that
period as well
so we know that that's kind of not going
to happen now with that we are now
seeing that the m2 based ships will be
inside of it and we also know that the
first m2 chips are going gonna be in the
lower end models like the macbooks and
maybe the mac mini so we would expect
that to happen later most likely in 2023
maybe this spring or later than that
meaning we have pretty much at least a
year wait for that new imac to come so
is it worth waiting a year well you
gotta ask yourself are you willing and
able to wait that long and with that if
you're not can you afford the extra
price of having to buy the mac studio
the display and keyboard mouse
separately if you can afford it or you
can't wait then i would pick one of
those up and with that if you need an
ultra chip with more cpu and graphics
cores that's likely going to stay in the
mac studio so that's another reason to
buy that mac studio now instead of
waiting for those of you guys that can
wait and you can
you don't want to spend the extra money
on the separate displays in mac studio i
would say go ahead and wait another year
for a better value all-in-one imac to be
released there you guys go that is why
we don't see the imac right now and also
when we'll get it check out the deep
dive right over there that we did you're
going to be very interested in that
click that circle about to subscribe
because we have a lot of content coming
out on the mac studio and this display
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you